thank you for joining us for today's
webinar how multiplex
microarray technology is revolutionizing
microbial testing in cannabis it is
presented by Milan Patel co-founder and
CEO of pathogen DX my name is Judy
O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming blonde patel i will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you so much this morning um I'm
pleased to be presenting how much
multiplexed microwave technology is
revolutionising microbial testing uh you
know as part of the lab Lutz virtual
webinar I'm Moe Patel co-founder and CEO
pathogen VX
part of 140 years you know the world's
being basically focused on microbial
testing and what I'm about to present is
really the future ahead and it's now and
things are simply about to change in the
world of testing
when you look at the cannabis testing
industry cannabis industry you will
notice that the it's ripe oak
contamination it's plagued with cigs
with a lot of contamination issues
across the entire supply chain and up to
30% of the industry has purity and
contamination issues starting from the
growers where labs are detected you know
contamination of yeast and mold
bacterial and fungal that that is
impacting the health and safety of the
public as well as the consumers in that
market
and as we all know there are over 30 or
so states that have legalized medical
marijuana and 10 or more that is that
have already have adult use and several
more that are currently on ballot what
these states have done is basically put
in a regulatory system that a lot that
that there is mandatory compliant
testing of cannabis that ultimately gets
to a patient or a consumer microbial
test is one of a handful of tests that a
certified independent test lab will be
required to do in a legalized state and
it's the one that is the longest out of
all of the tests that are conducted for
in a cannabis testing lab it normally
takes two to six days for results to be
delivered to a cultivator or I grower
all other cannabis tests take less than
two hours in terms of results so growers
are waiting for results from the
microbial test uh you know trying to get
their product to dispensaries so that
customers consumers and patients can
have access accessibility to the product
in the marketplace
just to take a few steps back we all
know that microbial testing effectively
is the testing of bacterial or fungal
contamination and for the better part of
a hundred and forty years the world has
pretty much used the classical petri
dish approach in identifying if a
product has been contaminated with E
coli or Salmonella the classic examples
that we are all familiar with is last
year the romaine lettuce outbreak where
ecoli effectively infected the product
and a lot of product had to mean
batik recalled or scrapped off the shelf
and previously we also had examples of
Chipotle the issue with the petri dish
technology although it's being used for
over a century is that it's simply too
slow as I mentioned earlier it takes
anywhere from two to six days it's
significantly variable you know where
the result can vary up to plus or minus
30% on either side of a failed past
threshold and lastly it's very costly it
requires a lot of waiting time and labor
time which is still costly in terms of
getting a result to to the growers
pathogen DX has created is a
game-changing disruptive technology that
allows to test for multiple pathogens
all at the same time in a single
reaction you can see a slide on on this
glass light on this side this
presentation cha has light with little
circles on them in the these particular
circles have the capability to test for
at least four to five dozen pathogens
per sample delivering significantly
faster turnaround time of results down
to six hours from two to six days it
gives labs a capability to process more
samples per day and let not have a
bottleneck in getting bogged down with a
lot of petri dishes yeah the platform
allows for what is called content
scalability and what that means is if
there is a strain of pathogen that is
that is that needs to be added it could
the technology can quickly add that
within sixty to ninety days to be able
to test for the latest bacterial or
fungal organisms that are you know that
are poor basically infecting our food or
water or or supply systems and in
addition to that it allows for a very
simple and easy testing process for the
lab there's automated controls and
built-in capability to make it user
foolproof and so it allows for less
human intervention in determining
whether you have the work you know what
the result is and lastly it basically
effectively you know can result in the
lowest analyte or organism test cost up
per test we're delivering high
performance results that that match to
the federal regulations of the FDA BAM
the AOA see appendix J for microbial
testing and the USDA USDA FS is testing
armed levels
so in a nutshell this new technology is
effectively called a microarray that
glass slide is a DNA based breakthrough
for microbial testing that can allow
labs to test a minimum of 96 samples per
day you know for over 50 pathogens per
sample all at the same time
so what's behind this technology well as
you can see on this slide there are
these wells or these little circles and
within the wells what we have done is we
printed a genetic sequences of up to 40
to 50 pathogens in back in these wells
and you can see these red and green dots
in this particular instance of red dots
mean normalized pathogen probes and and
you can you can see certain green dots
and green dots represent the detection
of a specific pathogen which gives us a
gives an intensity level of the amount
of of DNA contamination within within
that particular sample and then you can
see that also there's a there's a
repeatability of these of these dots in
three times within the well so what we
have delivered is a ability to test the
sample for whether it's a coli or
Salmonella or Aspergillus in triplicate
so what that means to the lab technician
is that every sample will have three
data points per ecoli to make sure that
you four bits with almost near hundred
percent confidence that you have
certainty in your result and that
there's no ambiguity between a pass and
a fail
and we repeated that that particular
pattern across all of these wells on
this glass slide so that you can you can
test multiple samples all at the same
time while testing for multiple
organisms in triplicate at the same time
so at the end of the day pathogen VX is
patented patented patented technology
delivers almost unmatched performance
and cost savings relative to the
conventional methods that have been used
for almost a century it delivers a much
faster turnaround time in the market
with almost less than six hours of
delivering results from the time you
hold up the you start processing the
sample in addition to that we can test
multiple pathogens at the same time down
to 0.1 see a few program detection
we can identify the source of the
contamination as well as the economics
are so advantages reducing the cost of
testing from by almost twenty to forty
five percent and then all of these
particular organisms are are these these
tests have been built around regulatory
optimized framework to ensure that the
technology is compliant to each state's
microbial testing regulations
so when we take a when we pause for a
moment the difference between how the
world has operated in microbial testing
for these organisms versus this new
technology it is truly the capability of
multiplex testing the ability to test
for all these organisms in the same
reaction at the same time and then also
being able to have cross applicability
across multiple markets whether it's the
food safety testing market or the
agricultural testing market as well as
the water market water testing market
and other markets that all required some
level of microbial testing all these
organisms are pretty much similar in
terms of being needed to be tested
across these markets and that's why you
have the capability to apply such a
technology for the benefit of
simplifying microbial testing not just
in cannabis but these are the markets
the other aspect of our technology
allows for the ability to extend the
testing across the full supply chain and
what this means is with with the when
you know with the with the technology
you can address
the source of contamination where it's
starting for example if it's an
agriculture it will be at the farm if
it's in cannabis it would be at the
grower and cultivator level and so what
we have right now is three key products
that are available in the market detect
acts that allows for simply weather
an organism such as e.coli is present or
absent in a sample
we also are about to introduce what is
called the quantex array which is the
ability for a lab or a grower to know
how much how much contamination is in
that sample is there is that is that
contamination level below or above
pass/fail threshold for a product to be
safe or unsafe and lastly we have an
environment
product which allows for an ultra-rapid
capability to detect up to 50 odd
pathogens both bacterial and fungal in
an environmental settings such as a grow
facility or a food processing house
a future product plan you know aims to
deliver a plant pathogen array which we
expect to deliver this summer they
mycotoxin array that we expect to
deliver at the end of this year or early
next year a gender X test as well as a
strain X test and all of these
particular tests are run up in the same
equipment in with the same protocol and
the same software so it greatly
simplifies the complexity that a lab has
to deal with with multiple tests in this
particular case the resources simply are
trained on one process for four seven
different tests and that's the key
driver in trying terms of driving both
predicted efficiency as well as
productivity within a lab to get the
results out better faster and cheaper
our product this is just a pictorial
view of not just the glass slides with
the micro arrays but also with the kit
and in this particular case we're
showing you a detector that allows for
the detection of pathogen bacterial and
fungal pathogens within the kit we we
provide a sample digestion buffer and a
prep buffer primers for low Sian Han
sment as well as labeling primers and a
BSA solution and then buffers for
hybridization as well as the eight
slides for for being able to test up to
48 bacterial and fungal organisms um you
know within each well
this particular slide basically gives a
sense of how we how we are target these
particular organisms and as you can see
there's the detect X chip and the
quantex chip that's shown to the right
and the specific bacterial organisms
that we are into interrogating as part
of the detect X and context as well as
the yeast and mold organisms and
specific genes as well as indicator
organisms that are required by state law
our focus is essentially to ensure that
the arrays that we are developing did
Hart automated from a controls
perspective with PCR positive and
negative controls as well as imager
controls that allow for a semi-automated
capability to know that the process was
handled appropriately when it was when
the test was run through a lab so it
relies less on human labor and
intervention and more in terms of
built-in controls to ensure consistency
robustness and repeatability of the test
I'd mentioned the enviro X kit a little
bit earlier what this particular esta
helps is it allows you to identify a
source of contamination and as I
mentioned earlier in the beginning of
this presentation up to 30% of the
cannabis industry is is dealing with
contamination issues so what we realized
as we were as we were developing this
technology and talking to many different
growers was that the actual source of
contamination was within their facility
within their cultivation environment and
we developed what is it what is called a
very simple ultra rapid swab and result
capability where you take a swab you
basically swab it across a rack or a
vent or a hood or working table surface
and then you can submit it to your lab
and within 24 hours have the ability to
know where at those locations that you
swab you will identify any one of these
50 pathogens that are that are able to
that are part of this kit and as you can
see there are quite a few organisms on
the bacterial side that are basically
you know notorious for creating huge
contamination issues within the within
the industry
this slide is the same slide as
previously but what it also covers are
some very important fungal organisms
such as powdery mildew root rot which is
boy Titus and pasaría as well as bio
foliar organisms that can help a grower
ensure that their crop is healthy and is
not it is not going to be at risk of
contamination
but one of the things we did was we we
made sure that when we develop this is
technology platform and the products off
of that platform that we had a great
plug-and-play optionality into not just
cannabis but also hemp and food and
agriculture and as you can see on this
matrix a lot of the tests that we have
developed are developing have cross
applicability into the market without
the need for a lot of rework redesign
and redevelopment and revalidation and
that was the the key focus of creating a
building block easy to use plug-and-play
option for labs that don't have to have
different sets of equipment for
different tests different protocols and
having to have multiple resources within
the lab and that's the key driver behind
the premise of this this technology to
make it a lot more easier for the labs
and you know deliver the result much
faster better and cheaper for the
markets that they support
now we all know that this there are
other sources of other testing options
such as I mentioned petri dish but there
is also you know a DNA best method
called real time PCR and what the
difference between the pathogen VX
technology and the and the qpcr or real
time PCR is is that the patent BX
technology does not require or
necessarily enrichment of the sample and
that saves literally one or two days of
enrichment time that other methods such
as the qpcr capability requires and so
the key takeaway here is is that by the
time you get the result off of the
pathogen VX array or platform
you still haven't prepped the sample
when you're using qPCR and that's the
difference with such a with such a high
value crop you know time is money and
it's very critical for a customer to get
the results of you know much quicker
than than having to wait for it while
using another method that might require
enrichment the the difference here is
that the the premise of platform is that
we have a patented approach and how we
we take the sample we do not need that
enrichment or incubation time we do not
need to necessarily extract purify or
quantify the amount of DNA before you I
you know can get a result and so that's
the key game changer of the technology
as well as in qPCR you still may be
required to do what is called single
analyte testing that means for example
in
case of the California regulations for
cannabis microbial testing there are six
organisms and so each of those organisms
will have to be run separately and if
you have 96 samples coming in on day one
um you know you would need to run 96 796
tests for e.coli first then for
salmonella then for Aspergillus flavors
fumigatus Niger and Tereus so it's
simply a very you know single Plex
meaning one at a time Adam Smith the
sort of you know Henry Ford assembly
line model relative to the PDX
technology which does multiplex testing
in parallel for all organisms at the
same time while not while not
necessarily needing enrichment or
incubation of that sample and so that's
the the key differentiator between the
PDX technology and what is currently
available in the market
so I just mentioned uh the the ability
to obviate the need for enrichment and
what what the the underpinnings of this
particular vaca advantage is basically a
technology called raw sample genotyping
it effectively means that you do not
need to purify the DNA quantified or
normalize it and no quality assessments
really needed for sample contamination
all of this is avoided in by avoiding
almost twenty steps or and/or minimum of
one to two days of time through a simple
one hour sample prep this means that the
lab will save significant time labor and
cost in getting to the answer sooner
the second part of the process is when
you when you've gone through the sample
prep and lysis process what we've done
is we've simplified what is called a low
science mental enhancement and labeling
PCR process for those of us that are not
scientist the low sign has meant is
simply once you have I then once you
have once you have basically taken your
sample and you have gotten you basically
cracked open the the cells in NI and
identified the the pathogenic DNA the
low tsiyon has meant PCR will
effectively multiply and amplify the
pathogenic DNA in that sample and then
the labeling PCR is effectively applying
a fluorescent marker to that pathogenic
DNA so that you can effectively identify
it essentially this is done
simplistically by having less reagents
as opposed to the number of privates
excuse me the prime is needed for qPCR
you only need one bacterial primer in
one fungal primer for all these
organisms and that makes it a lot lot
easier in terms of complexity management
for a lab
after putting a fluorescent marker on
the sample what generally is required is
that you would then take the sample and
then you would basically drop it on to
one of those wells
the microarrays on that glass slide it
would essentially hybridize at ambient
temperature so there's no cooling or
heating requirement it just sits there
for thirty minutes you effectively wash
it you dry it and then your image it and
as you can see on this particular slide
you see a triplicate pattern of the dots
in the center image to the right where
you see red dots as well as green dots
and as I mentioned these particular dots
will represent the actual bacterial
fungal organisms in terms of probes for
detecting quantifying the organism and
again it should be mentioned that we
made the array where it's triplicate
data points per organism to get a
definitive pass or fail related to that
sample
once you image the data image that well
it creates a pip image and that TIFF
image is effectively process oft we're
in the cloud processes that TIFF image
through a dot scoring software program
and then identifies which organisms were
basically we're basically identified in
that sample and then delivers a a result
in the kaesong arm in the case of
quantification and liver it'll deliver a
see a few equivalent data set to
identify how much contamination there is
related to see equivalency of use within
that sample
so when we are when we take a step back
I've sort of described it sort of the
you know the overarching process what we
what we've done is when we look at the
number you know the process itself in
terms of equipment throughput and
scalability where we focused in terms of
make through making sure there's no
bottleneck is the imager can image up to
forty examples you know in eight minutes
after scanning with the real-time data
reporting so if you if a lab has 96
samples and in in a month goes from 90s
examples to to 198 samples 192 samples
all it would take is another three or
four thousand dollar thermal cycler to
process it and not a thirty to forty
thousand dollar piece of equipment you
know so we made it more cost affordable
and capital efficient for labs to
process you know more samples where the
focus would be not having to spend can
you know ten times more money for for
the next hundred samples it's only
incremental capital investment of
another three to four four thousand
dollars
as far as the simple the equipment is
concerned there's really only three
unique pieces of equipment you see Anna
migrator on the left that is by far the
largest piece of equipment which is the
most unique part of the process for the
PDX
technology there's a three to four
thousand dollar thermal cycler you can
see that in the middle and an air
aspiration system on the right that will
draw you fluid off of the wells
everything else is standard lab
equipment that most labs have such as
multi-channel capadders hand vortexes
centrifuges and so we've ensured that
there's very very few or very little
unique pieces of equipment needed as
part of this process in terms of a
layout you do not need a cleanroom you
don't need a separate pcr room all you
need is three tables that are that are
set up in a in a unidirectional flow and
so effectively it can be in a horseshoe
pattern but with a certain level of
distance away from it not a lot of table
space required as you can see there will
only be 30 square feet of real table
square footage when you look at it as
you know a three by six is roughly 18
square foot so you're really looking at
three three six foot tables set up a
certain way and really nothing beyond
that and there's no not unnecessary need
for a hood you can certainly use a hood
if you would like but it's not necessary
as part of the equipment set
so some of you may be wondering well how
does a pathogen DX system compare to
other technologies and what we've shown
here is basically a plate count or plate
culture 3 and Petri film technology and
medicinal genomics qpcr technology and a
bio marry you
eliza and liquid culture technology and
at the end of the day for labs you know
total test cost which means materials
labor overhead and you know and indirect
all over the indirect expenses
associated with it such as the wait time
we have provided that with respect to a
sample and as you can see the pathogen
DX is almost 25 to 40 percent or more
cheaper or lower cost than these other
technologies we've been able to get the
level of sensitivity and specificity of
the technology much better than any of
the other technologies down to 0.1 CFU
the turnaround time is less than 6 hours
versus days for the other ones primarily
because the other methods require
enrichment and then we can test for
multiplex organisms all of them at the
same time in the same reaction and then
we also have in built-in internal
triplicate controls versus these other
methods are that have external basically
organism controlled meaning primary
controls for the organisms you're
testing at the end of the day so that
makes it a lot more efficient in terms
of setup
for the better part of two to three
decades there's always been a you know
motive different types of thought as to
when you bring a sample and should you
enrich or not and effectively you know
for the pathogen DX technology
enrichment is not necessary we we have
conclusive validation data on cannabis
matrices to show that the PD X
technology as equal or better
sensitivity and specificity without the
need for enrichment versus other methods
and so there's always the proverbial
question that a lab director may ask is
to enrich or not to enrich that is the
question either way the PD X has have
you know technology covers that you can
you don't need to enrich but you can
certainly want to if you need to but
what key takeaway here is that there are
enough scientific peer-reviewed journal
articles across multiple industries
whether it's the pharmaceutical industry
or the food safety industry or or other
industries clinical chemistry articles
that have shown that enrichment biases
and skews the result at the end of the
day and that's the key takeaway is that
I you know um there's enough evidence
out there to say that one should not
necessarily need to enrich when you're
doing microbial testing you know for for
specific matrix
the other aspect of every lab is
obviously labor in the case of a PDA in
the case of a cannabis lab there have to
run at least half a dozen tests they've
got limited resources labour time is
scarce and so with the PDX technology
you can you can run up to 96 samples
there's only 2 hours of real hands-on
labor needed and at the end of the day
and so what this particular table shows
is the amount of you know amount of you
know labour time that the PDX technology
saves relative to these other methods
and you can see that it's material
because we've made it more semi semi /
automated and with it with it with the
amount of hands-on time needed to run a
test
covered really the merits and the
benefits and and the process of the PDX
technology the future is now a complete
change from really how we tested
compared to the past and where PDX is
now the new standard in DNA testing so
I'd like to thank you for the time and
listening to me I hope you enjoyed this
this culprit not this presentation
regarding the new DNA base testing by
pathogen DX thank you thank you Millan
for that informative presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 28 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you next time goodbye